firstly just thank you for bringing this
subject to light
it's very clearly one of the most
traumatic experiences a family can go
through in fact is having a loved one
arrested not just for a criminal offense
but for a child's sex offense which is
deemed by Society to be perhaps one of
the most heinous crimes there is
um the impact it will have on families
is substantial for any wives Partners
parents siblings that's a loved one who
has done something horrific and that
takes time to come to terms with for
wives in particular there is the man
they know and love and may have been
married to for a long time and that
image of that man does not ring true
with what they have done online and and
what they're being held to account for
for children it's incredibly difficult
and for mothers who have children it's
also incredibly difficult we have the
stop it now helpline which is available
to mothers and we speak to about a
thousand women a year in this situation
and they all have very different
experiences but they all have very
similar questions how could he do this
why did he do this what risks does he
pose to Children my child what is going
to happen with Children's Services why
aren't the police sharing information
with me it is a terribly traumatic time
and what we know from our research which
we've done recently
um this trauma doesn't stop after the
arrest it keeps going and it keeps
giving for months and possibly years
um and it it it it it shouldn't be
underestimated in in any way
and briefly if possible just how much
support is there out there and do you
think there should be more briefly
there's not enough so support for
families is sporadic it is rather a
postcode Lottery
um families are often left to seek that
support themselves and if they're lucky
they will find hours stop it now
helpline or they'll find safer Lives who
run a talking forward peer support group
or they'll find children seen and heard
there aren't many services about
um and then they're really ought to be
more for families and for children it is
the mothers who were left often trying
to navigate scenarios with very little
support
um and and yes in summary there ought to
be more
well yes and what about what rules
police work under for example at the
moment of arrest
it's difficult for police at the moment
of arrest they they have a duty of care
they have safeguarding responsibilities
um they need to make sure that if there
are children in the house those children
are safe
um what we would say that alongside all
of that there is a duty of care to the
family and there is a duty to reduce the
trauma as much as possible so a recent
report we've put out one of the
recommendations is around making sure
that trained police teams conduct
investigations and execute warrants and
that families are left with information
um so that they can
be aware of what Littles to help those
available they can call our helpline
they don't have to feel completely alone
but they need to be made aware of that